Incredible.
Ellen, I love you.
To my fellow nominees, I'm so proud to share this journey with you.
I'm in awe and I have so much respect for you all.
To the Academy, thank you.
In 1971, Bossier City, Louisiana, there was a teenage girl...
...who was pregnant with her second child.
She was a high school dropout and a single mom.
But somehow, she managed to make a better life for herself and her children.
She encouraged her kids to be creative, to work hard and to do something special.
That girl is my mother and she's here tonight.
And I just want to say I love you, mom.
Thank you for teaching me to dream.
To my brother Shannon, the best big brother in the world,...
...you're a true artist.
Thank you so much for sharing this insane and amazing adventure that is 30 Seconds to Mars...
...and for being my best friend.
I love you.
Thank you.
To all the dreamers out there around the world watching this tonight...
...in places like the Ukraine and Venezuela.
I wanna say we are here...
...and as you struggle to make your dreams happen, to live the impossible,...
...we're thinking of you tonight.